if you want to see how the father could
have survived while still saving as kids
stick around to the end of this video so
I checked out a quiet place again and
notice some new things you missed that I
wanted to share with whoever is out
there and still alive and has a pair of
headphones but first I wanted to address
something from the last video which you
should go here and watch before watching
this video I got so many comments saying
that the red lights were not meant to
herd the creatures that they're just
assigned to be on red alert
because there are aliens in the area or
because the baby was being born I
totally agree that is the purpose of the
red lights and I didn't mean for it to
come off in any other way what I was
saying was that when the wife turns on
the red lights there's an unmistakable
high-pitched sound emitted from them go
back and watch the scene and you'll see
what I mean but I don't know if this is
an intended side effect of having the
red lights on or if it was just a happy
accident but it does seem to throw the
monsters off by a little bit providing
the family with a long string of
continuous sound just as the river
offered protection from small noises
this on an even quieter level may have
afforded them a little leeway and needed
to move around the house but other than
the volume another difference between
the river and the string of red lights
is that the sound coming from the lights
is a much higher frequency and as we saw
from the hearing aid an extremely high
frequency sound can hurt the monsters
and make them vulnerable so when I
talked about the opening shot of the
movie with the traffic light taken down
I was just saying that that could be a
clue for the audience as to what the
weakness might be when watching the
movie again I noticed perhaps even more
evidence towards this after the baby is
born when the father comes up from the
bunker to find the two older kids the
string lights are now ripped from the
ceiling and on the floor the aliens
didn't really attack anything else in
the house other than the water pipe
which may have been inadvertent just
like the pipe happened to intersect with
where the lights were set up but like I
said the main purpose of those lights
was a visual cue for everyone to be on
high alert because obviously blasting a
siren or something wouldn't work in
their favor there was one other thing in
the last video that I got more evidence
for the second time around which was my
theory that the creatures are in fact
aliens remember last time we had this
shot which was used in the trailer but
not the movie this time I noticed a
couple more headlines
stood up in the father's basement lab
first red meteorite hits Mexico which
gives us a clue about where and how the
epidemic started if you're wondering
where a quiet place takes place there's
a newspaper stand in town that says
Little Falls New York so the family we
see in the movie had some time to
prepare before the aliens made their way
across North America to get to them
there was another headline I caught that
was way in the background and partially
cut off screen I saw the letters a li e
so I'm assuming that says aliens and I
think we've got enough to confirm now
that these creatures are
extraterrestrials my question is what
did the father do before the apocalypse
that left him so well prepared I think
it's likely he was some kind of
telecommunications expert because of all
the equipment he has but he also sets up
his own video surveillance and has a
printed list of every country keep in
mind he would have had to have that list
printed before the invasion started
because printers are loud so what do you
think he did before the takeover and why
didn't he want his daughter going into
the basement leave your ideas in the
comments one thing you may or may not
have noticed early on that certainly
went past me was the seriousness of the
opening scene the family goes into the
drugstore to get pills for the older son
who is sick it's pretty scary to think
that even a simple cough could be deadly
in this world because of the noise minor
congestion could lead to snoring which
could also be dangerous that's why the
father has medical supplies written on
his whiteboard
because staying healthy becomes
extremely important I'm guessing they go
into town for supplies fairly often
because the father actually lays down a
sand path all the way into town to quiet
their footsteps there were a couple
other things I noticed that they did to
keep things quiet like painting the
floorboards that don't creak a slightly
different color someone else in the
comments talked about the reason the
hearing aid bugs out around the alien
I had previously said that it could be
because of a feedback loop but this
person suggested that the aliens might
give off some kind of electromagnetic
waves that mess with electronics there
seems to be even more evidence for this
when the wife goes into labor a light
bulb above bath flickers as the alien
comes up the stairs we see the same
thing happen in the basement to a
smaller lamp and when the monster goes
down near the surveillance screens they
all turn to static after the creature is
killed they return to normal I did pick
up something very interesting in the
early going about the younger son it
almost seems like he doesn't have the
will to live quietly kids are always
loud and obnoxious and maybe they need
to get that energy out by making noise
he draws a rocket ship on the floor of
the drugstore and tells his sister
that's how we get away then he
intentionally put the batteries back in
and turns on the rocket on the bridge so
he essentially uses the rocket to get
away from this life that he hates it's a
dark way of looking at it but after
seeing it again it does look to be
intentional I thought it was strange
that they let this kid trail behind the
pack like that I mean if he were to have
wandered off they would have likely
never found him they wouldn't be able to
call out his name when they went
searching for him which would make it
pretty much impossible to find him I
would have kept the kid in front and
towards the end of the movie there was
something else I would have done
differently as well the dad's last
action to save his kids was to yell out
and distract the alien trying to get
into the car that the kids were hiding
in moments before he grabs an axe from
the tool shed and tries to fight the
creature off which doesn't work I think
all he had to do was throw the axe back
into the tool shed and aim to knock over
some stuff in there that should have
before de-dum the time to flee the other
thing I thought about was the fact that
the baby is born on day 473 and comes
about two weeks early that means the
baby must have been conceived around day
259 almost a year into the invasion so
what does that mean aside from probably
some really boring quiet sex it means
they intentionally brought a child into
this world most likely to try to do
whatever they could to prevent mankind
from dying out so there may actually be
some religious symbolism to match the
themes of perpetuating
the first being that the baby is
mentioned to be male when the nursery is
flooded the baby seems to be floating in
that wood box the image is reminiscent
of baby Moses being sent down the river
in a wood basket to survive the
Israelites I also found the old couple
seemed to be significant the father
takes a son to the river to show him how
to survive on his own then they come
across the old couple the woman is dead
and the man gives himself up this is a
symbolic passing of the torch from old
to new the boy experiences a rite of
passage and at the end of the movie
he'll be expected to rise up and become
the man of the household and I'm gonna
refer to the newspapers one more time
for another religious connotation more
than one publication refers to the
aliens as angels of death or dark angels
of destruction which could go back to
the idea of the new baby representing
Moses and the Angel of Death
passing over him if you're interested in
that kind of stuff and go check out my
things you missed on mother where I go
much more in depth about the religious
symbolism from Aronofsky's latest flag
just make sure you stay quiet and stay
safe and stay up-to-date on my new
videos by subscribing this Easy's world
for new Horrors every week bring the
death belt for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]